У Німеччині стартує нова епоха. Без Меркель.
Після 16 років при владі вона більше не очолює уряд ФРН.
Нова урядова коаліція тепер складається із соціал-демократів, лібералів та Зелених.
А новим канцлером став Олаф Шольц.
Зважаючи на те, що його Соціал-демократична партія традиційно більш лояльна до Росії,
а її колишній лідер і ексканцлер Ґергард Шредер нині лобіює "Газпром", якими ж будуть відносини з Україною?
Опитані DW експерти запевняють, що Шольц швидше за все продовжуватиме політику Меркель щодо України.
Звісно, український суверенітет, український розвиток та євроінтеграція лежать в основі принципів
німецької зовнішньої політики, і Шольц їх дотримуватиметься.
Я не думаю, що Шольц - це другий Шредер. Шольц у своїй політиці буде ближчим до Меркель, ніж до Шредера.
Нова коаліція в Німеччині обрала жорсткіший тон щодо Росії.
У коаліційній угоді не лише згадано, що анексія Криму суперечить міжнародному праву,
а й вимагається від Росії "негайно покласти їй край", як і "насильству на Сході України".
Політологи зазначають: це, ймовірно, пов'язано з тим, що у ФРН вже не мають ілюзій,
що найближчими роками Росія піде шляхом демократії та європейських цінностей.
У Німеччині розпрощалися з метою залучити Росію до європейського канону цінностей,
демократизувати її чи вивести на європейський шлях розвитку.
І я вважаю, що для майбутнього німецько-російських відносин дуже важливо мати реалістичну оцінку щодо того,
чого справді можна досягти у відносинах з Росією.
Класична парадигма східноєвропейської політики - зміни за допомогою торгівлі - цього разу повністю відсутня.
Натомість увага зосереджена на мінімізації та управлінні ризиками щодо Росії.
При цьому якщо попередній уряд, попри анексію Криму і роль Москви у конфлікті на Донбасі,
наголошував, що все одно прагне, цитата, "хороших" відносин з Росією,
то у нинішній угоді вже йдеться не про "хороші" відносини, а про готовність до "змістовних і стабільних" відносин з Росією.
Загалом очевидно, що тон стосовно Росії став різкішим.
У тексті договору висунуто вимогу до Росії припинити спроби дестабілізації України та ще цілу низку вимог.
Висувається чітке побажання більшої безпеки у Східній Європі
та дотримання інтересів центрально- та східноєвропейських держав.
Водночас, за словами політолога, ці побажання не складаються у єдину концепцію,
і в цьому сенсі коаліційний договір поки що не дає чітких обрисів майбутньої німецької зовнішньої політики щодо України.
Крім того, одна з небагатьох зовнішньополітичних тем, які обговорювалися під час передвиборчої кампанії -
"Північний потік-2" - у коаліційному договорі взагалі не згадується.
Соціал-демократи підтримують цей проєкт.
А Зелені і ліберали у своїх передвиборчих програмах вимагали його зупинки.
Зрештою, нові урядові партії вирішили взагалі не згадувати цей проєкт у коаліційній угоді.
З точки зору уряду ФРН, це дуже розумно - не вписувати положення щодо "Північного потоку-2" в коаліційний договір,
щоб потім не бути спійманим на слові.
Як мені здається, було би бажано, щоб Росія визнала наступне:
"Північний потік-2" і газові поставки - це не тільки важіль тиску з боку Росії проти Європи,
а й інструмент, яким Європа може користуватися і проти Росії - рішуче і не боячись зупинити цей проєкт.
Важливу роль для майбутніх українсько-німецьких та російсько-німецьких відносин може зіграти й те,
що портфель міністра закордонних справ отримали Зелені, а саме співголова партії Анналена Бербок.
Тож є надія, що зусилля України щодо відновлення своєї територіальної цілісності
будуть активніше підтримуватися Берліном, а дії Росії не залишаться без уваги, зауважує німецька політологиня.
Зелені традиційно надають велику увагу боротьбі з корупцією, підтримці демократизації тощо.
Дотримання прав людини - це також важливе питання.
Це може стати серйозною проблемою для Росії, де всі ці речі не так сильно дотримуються у внутрішній політиці, як хотілося б Зеленим.
І що також характерне для Зелених, так це те, що вони надають набагато більше уваги іншим країнам Східної Європи,
окрім Росії, тобто насамперед Україні, а також Молдові чи Південному Кавказу.
Це означає, що може статися свого роду зміщення пріоритетів Берліна від Москви
у бік інших східноєвропейських столиць, вважають експерти.
Але багато чого залежить від того, наскільки сильною фігурою у новому уряді буде голова МЗС.
Зовнішньополітичне відомство було слабким у попередніх урядах,
ініціативу з багатьох питань перебрало на себе відомство федерального канцлера.
Анналена Бербок - молода і енергійна політикиня. У неї є всі шанси ствердитися на цій посаді.
Водночас уявлення німецьких Зелених про те, як підтримувати Україну у протистоянні з Росією,
можуть дуже відрізнятись від очікувань Києва.
Яскравим свідченням цього став візит до України співголови партії Роберта Габека.
Спершу політик сказав, що не виключає поставок оборонного озброєння до України.
Утім, одразу після повернення до Німеччини Габек дав задню і заявив,
що поділяє позицію Анналени Бербок про те, що зброю Німеччина Україні не постачатиме.
Зрештою Зелені в один голос стали говорити, що Україні треба постачати
хіба що засоби для розмінування і транспортування поранених.